>>> NEW DETAILS THIS MORNING IN
THE INVESTIGATION INTO FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S STORAGE OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
WE ARE LEARNING THE FBI
INTERVIEWED HIS FORMER TOP
LAWYERS PAT CIPOLLONE AND
PATRICK PHIL BIN EARLIER THIS
YEAR AFTER WHICH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NOTICED SOMETHING
ALARMING ON SUBPOENAED
MAR-A-LAGO SURVEILLANCE TAPE.
CNN'S KATELYN POLANTZ JOINS US
NOW WITH THE LATEST ON THIS.
>> BRIANNA, EVERYTHING WE ARE
LEARNING HERE IS SHOWING HOW THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ARRIVED TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY FELT IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO GO INTO
MAR-A-LAGO A WEEK AGO AND SEIZE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE BEING KEPT
THERE.
THIS NEW INFORMATION NOW IS
FILLING OUT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW WE GOT TO THAT POINT.
OUR EVAN PEREZ AND GABBY ORR
WERE ABLE TO CONFIRM YESTERDAY
THAT PAT CIPOLLONE AND PATRICK
PHILBIN WERE INTERVIEWED BY THE
FBI EARLIER THIS YEAR.
CIPOLLONE AND PHILBIN WERE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL OFFICE.
CIPOLLONE WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL ITSELF AND PHILBIN WAS A
DEPUTY TO HIM.
AFTER THE PRESIDENCY THEY BECAME
LIAISONS TO DONALD TRUMP TO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES DEALING WITH
HIS PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
WHENEVER THIS WAS HAPPENING,
THIS WAS AROUND THE TIME EARLIER
THIS YEAR WHERE THE
INVESTIGATION WAS REALLY ROBUST,
THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
INVESTIGATORS WERE DOING.
THEY WERE INTERVIEWING WITNESSES
SUCH AS THEM, THEY WERE
SUBPOENAING THE DOCUMENTS TO TRY
TO GET THEM BACK.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS SAID
THAT PHILBIN AND CIPOLLONE WERE
TRYING TO HELP GET THOSE
DOCUMENTS RETRIEVED FOR THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORTING WHICH FIRST
BROKE THIS STORY THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS
SUBPOENAING SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE
AND ON THAT SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE
AT MAR-A-LAGO SAW SOMETHING THAT
CONCERNED THEM THAT THEN
PRECIPITATED THIS SEARCH
ULTIMATELY THIS MONTH.
ALL OF THIS PUT TOGETHER, ALL OF
THIS, WOULD BE OUTLINED IN THAT
SECRET AFFIDAVIT THAT IS IN THE
COURT RECORD THAT BACKED UP THE
PROBABLE CAUSE THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NEEDED TO CONVINCE A
JUDGE THAT THEY SHOULD TAKE THIS
UNUSUAL STEP OF GOING INTO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOME IN
FLORIDA.
>> AND ABOUT THAT AFFIDAVIT,
THERE IS A HEARING TOMORROW
ABOUT IT, THE PRECURSOR TO THE
SEARCH WARRANT, AND WHETHER THE
PUBLIC IS GOING TO SEE IT.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THIS HEARING TOMORROW IT IS
BEFORE THE JUDGE THAT SIGNED THE
SEARCH WARRANT, APPROVED T THE
JUDGE WOULD HAVE SEEN THIS
AFFIDAVIT BEFORE AND THIS
HEARING THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TOMORROW IN FLORIDA IT IS ABOUT
SECRECY.
RIGHT NOW THE MEDIA AND OTHERS
POTENTIALLY HAVE BEEN ASKING TO
SEE THIS AFFIDAVIT AS IS OUR
RIGHT TO ASK FOR, AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS ARGUING
VERY STRONGLY THAT THEY CAN'T
LET THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE THERE
ARE SUCH SENSITIVE DETAILS IN
THERE, SUCH A SENSITIVE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION INVOLVING HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL THAT THEY DO
NOT WANT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
OUT THERE.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS LEGAL TEAM THEY
HAVE NOT SEEN THIS AFFIDAVIT, IT
WOULD HAVE A NARRATIVE OF A LOT
OF THE INVESTIGATIVE STEPS TAKEN
AND THIS MORNING -- I'M SORRY,
TOMORROW MORNING WE ARE WAITING
TO SEE IF TRUMP'S TEAM SPEAKS UP
IN COURT AND SAYS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT THIS TO BE RELEASED OR
NOT.
ULTIMATELY IT WILL BE UP TO THE
JUDGE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
KATELYN, THANK YOU FOR THAT NEW
REPORTING.
>>> WITH US NOW FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT GENERAL ELLIOT
WILLIAMS AND FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI ANDREW
McCABE.
A HELL OF A QUOTE FROM MAGGIE
HABERMAN IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
AND HER REPORTING ABOUT PHILBIN
AND CIPOLLONE BEING QUESTIONED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT SAYS, QUOTE, MR. PHILBIN
TRIED TO HELP THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES RETRIEVE THE MATERIAL,
TWO M PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH THE
DISCUSSION SAID, BUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT REPEATEDLY RESISTED
AND TREATIES FROM HIS ADVISERS,
QUOTE, IT'S NOT THEIRS, IT'S
MINE, SEVERAL ADVISERS SAY MR.
TRUMP TOLD THEM.
>> A COUPLE THINGS, ONE, JOHN,
THERE IS THIS QUESTION OF
WHETHER CIPOLLONE AND PHILBIN
ARE IN TROUBLE BASED ON THEIR
ROLE ON THIS.
NO, THESE WERE THE PEOPLE
STANDING BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND SOME OF HIS WORST IMPULSES
AND THIS WHOLE IDEA OF THEY'RE
NOT MINE -- IT'S MINE, IT'S
NOT -- THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
INCORRECT.
THEY ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
DOCUMENTS.
EVEN IF THEY HAD BEEN
DECLASSIFIED THEY'RE GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
STORED PROPERLY IN A DIFFERENT
WAY OTHER THAN AT THE
PRESIDENT'S PRIVATE RESIDENCE.
>> WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU,
THOUGH, IN THE ISSUE OF INTENT
HERE, THEY ARE NOT THEIRS,
THEY'RE MINE.
>> IT TELLS YOU A LOT.
ANY OF US WHO HAVE RAISED
CHILDREN HAVE HAD A ERRED THAT
SAME RESPONSE IN A NUMBER OF
CONTEXTS, IT DOESN'T INDICATE A
HIGH DEGREE OF UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT OR
PROPERTY LAW FOR THAT MATTER.
I THINK THAT'S BEEN CLEAR FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING, THERE IS AN
INTENTIONALITY HERE.
THE SIMPLE FACT THAT THESE
DISCUSSIONS BEGAN WITH THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES, CONTINUED FOR
ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS AND IN
JANUARY OF COURSE THE TRUMP TEAM
TURNED OVER A THIRD OF WHAT THEY
HAD TO THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH
EVERYTHING.
THEY GAVE OVER 15 BOXES, WE KNOW
THAT THE FBI WAS ABLE TO RECOVER
AN ADDITIONAL 33.
SO THERE IS INTENTION I CAN'T
TELL THERE IN THAT SORT AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THEY WILL HAVE
TO EXPLAIN.
>> LET'S STICK ON INTENTIONALITY
HERE, IT'S NOT THEIRS, IT'S
MINE.
THAT SEEMS TO PRECLUDE THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE THERE BY ACCIDENT.
IF HE'S SAYING THEY'RE MINE --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> RIGHT?
DOESN'T THAT PUT IT IN A
DIFFERENT LEGAL CATEGORY
POTENTIALLY?
>> HE ACTUALLY MIGHT BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE HIS AND TOOK THEM
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE INTENDING
TO TAKE THEM OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU'VE BEEN A
SENIOR GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL, I'VE
BEEN A SENIOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL, YOU ARE WARNED FROM
THE DAY YOU GET IN MULTIPLE
TIMES THROUGHOUT AND I ON THE
DAY YOU LEAVE THAT THESE ARE NOT
YOUR DOCUMENTS AND YOU HAVE TO
TURN THEM OVER.
AS A PRESIDENT THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER UNDER THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.
WE TRIED HAVING UNACCOUNTABLE
LEADERS IN THE UNITED STATES FOR
PROBABLY THE FIRST HALF OF
AMERICAN HISTORY IT DIDN'T WORK
OUT WELL AND I THINK YOU'RE
SEEING SOME OF THAT HERE.
>> ANDY -- SORRY, GO ON.
YOU WERE GOING TO SAY SOMETHING.
>> NO, I JUST -- I THINK WE HAVE
TO PUT IT IN THE CONTEXT OF AT
LEAST ONE OF THE MANY DEFENSES
WE HAVE HEARD SO FAR, THIS WAS
GSA'S FAULT, IT WAS THROWN INTO
THE WRONG BOXES AND THEY TOOK
THE THINGS TO MAR-A-LAGO.
I THINK THE IT'S MINE COMMENT
UNDERMINES THAT DEFENSE.
>> HOW MUCH INSIGHT CAN THEY
PROVIDE KNOWING THAT THEY'RE
STEERING AWAY FROM STUFF THAT
THEY -- ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE, THIS ISSUE HAS NOT
BEEN RESOLVED YET, HOW MUCH
INSIGHT CAN THEY PROVIDE INTO
HOW THESE DOCUMENTS WERE HANDLED
WITHOUT GOING INTO SOME OF THAT?
>> WELL, THAT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH.
OBVIOUSLY THAT WILL BUMP UP
AGAINST WHAT WE'VE SEEN AS A
SERIES OF CLAIMS OF PRIVILEGE
AND ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES REGARDING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS STAFFERS.
HOWEVER, THE REVELATION -- AND
I'M SURE IT WAS A REVELATION FOR
THE FBI AGENTS WHO ATTENDED THAT
MEETING AT MAR-A-LAGO IN JUNE,
THAT THERE WAS APPARENTLY
SURVEILLANCE COVERAGE OUTSIDE
THE ROOM THAT WOULD INDICATE WHO
WAS HAVING ACCESS TO THAT ROOM,
HOW OFTEN PEOPLE WERE GOING IN
THERE, WHAT THAT TRAFFIC LOOKED
LIKE, THAT BECAME A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT FOR THEM AND
THAT WOULD EXPLAIN WHY THEY
SUBPOENAED THAT COVERAGE --
>> LET ME READ ANOTHER QUOTE
FROM MAGGIE HABERMAN'S REPORTING
THAT DEALING WITH SURVEILLANCE
FOOTAGE AND THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE ALARMED WITH WHAT THEY SAW.
AT THAT POINT AT LEAST ONE TRUMP
LAWYER SIGNED A STATEMENT SAYING
MATERIAL WITH THE CLASSIFIED
MARKINGS HAD BEEN RETURNED
ACCORDING TO FOUR PEOPLE
FAMILIAR WITH THE DOCUMENT BUT
OFFICIALS USED A SUBPOENA TO
OBTAIN SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE OF
THE HALLWAY OUTSIDE A STORAGE
ROOM AT MAR-A-LAGO AND SAW
SOMETHING THAT ALARMED THEM.
THEY ALSO RECEIVED INFORMATION
FROM AT LEAST ONE WITNESS WHO
INDICATED THAT MORE MATERIAL
MIGHT REMAIN AT THE RESIDENCE.
PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION SAID.
>> OH, MY LORD, IT'S LIKE A LAW
SCHOOL EXAM QUESTION WHERE YOU
HAVE TO COUNT ALL OF THE CRIMES.
I'M DEAD SERIOUS HERE.
NUMBER ONE, SIGNING THAT
DOCUMENT COULD ITSELF BE A CRIME
BECAUSE IT'S A FALSE STATEMENT
TO THE GOVERNMENT, NUMBER TWO,
NOT COMPLYING WITH THE SUBPOENA,
IT'S A MISDEMEANOR BUT STILL A
CRIME.
NUMBER THREE, WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
ARE POTENTIALLY CRIMES OR AT
LEAST GROSS ABUSES IN JUDGMENT
HAPPENING ON CAMERA.
AND THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
WHEN BUILDING INVESTIGATIONS,
THEY HAD EVIDENCE AND TESTIMONY
AND A BACKGROUND OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON AND THEN WERE TRIGGERED
BY SOMETHING THEY SAW ON CAMERA
THAT SAID SOMETHING DOESN'T LOOK
RIGHT HERE.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH THIS
MORNING.
THANKS FOR COMING IN.